today we're gonna explain the evidence
behind way back ago specifically an
adult version of the character was the
second user of one for all and why this
theory makes perfect sense I posted this
theory on Twitter the other day and it
literally blew up with 90% of the
replies telling me how it exploded their
minds in several different directions
and it was also pretty cool to have some
big youtubers like true Theroux
chiming in with their opinions even
though he was wrong sorry bro the core
of this theory actually hinges on
understanding four characters other than
back ago so let's start with them so
you'll understand the context and this
is super important so even if you think
you know these characters just believe
me you need to listen the whole way so
to start with we have the brother of
all-4-one a guy with a righteous heart
who supposedly had no quirk this
character was nothing like his older
brother so much so that all for one
tried to make him submit by forcefully
giving his little brother a stock power
piling quark this would of course then
go on to become the power known as one
for all and for those of you that don't
know one flaw was created due to the
stock power piling quark combining with
the brothers secret quark that no one
knew about this secret power allowed the
brother to transfer quirks to other
people but only if they ate his DNA and
whilst they were doing that he had to
simultaneously want his quote to be
transferred now moving on the next
character you need to know about is
Shigure aki and at this point i'm going
to go into some big big spoiler
territory for the manga so if you really
don't want to know any spoilers then
this is the end of the video for you my
friend
currently in the manga shigaraki is
undergoing an operation from dr. EG KO
that will give him an immense power of
some kind and the doctor says on this
page that once the operation is complete
everything will be within Shigure our
keys grasp including one for all
remember up until this point one for all
could never be taken by force as it can
only be transferred when the person
holding it wants it to be passed on and
from this wording in the manga is pretty
obvious that Shigure aki will somehow
have a means of taking one for all by
force in the near future the third
character we need to be aware of is [ __ ]
Rocky's grandmother Nana shamora she was
the seventh holder of one for all and
during her hero days
mentioned that the feelings of previous
one for all users can be recorded inside
one for all essentially what that means
is that these spirits of one for all
users live on inside the quark and that
future users can see the memories of
previous users this has been
demonstrated in the manga when duck who
saw the memories of the first user of
one for all and then interacted with him
and finally the last character that we
need to understand is arey a character
who's been introduced in season four
every is a six year old girl who has a
powerful quirk
called rewind and I actually did a video
breaking this quirk down in more detail
but here's just a high level overview
every can manipulate time on an
individual scale meaning she can rewind
living things back into a previous state
so for example if she touched you she
could probably rewind you back into a
baby or rewind you so far that you never
even existed now it's important to
remember that not only is Airi just six
years old but she has never once in her
life trained her quirk consequently
whilst we've only seen her apply this
rewind quirk on an individual scale it's
not a stretch to say that with practice
and focus she could be able to rewind on
a much bigger scale
if deku can achieve such rapid growth on
his first day of meeting gran torino
could you imagine if re a six year old
child had a few years to train her quirk
and apply it in different ways it's just
something to think about but with all
that explained let's get into the main
crux of this theory of how BAC ago is
the second user of one for all so to
start with during a certain arc in the
manga Deku essentially went inside the
core of one for all and was able to see
the spirits of its previous users now
when we zoom in at the end here we see
two characters who've been intentionally
blurred out by Hiroko XI one of whom
will immediately catch your attention I
mean it's not even just the hair look at
the gauntlets on his arm
this clearly looks like a silhouette of
a more grown-up version of back ago and
let's be real if I showed you this
silhouette in a totally different
context and asked you which character
you think this is come on there's no way
you're not saying back ago horikoshi is
a writer who has meaning behind every
panel he writes the fact that he's
intentionally blurring out this
silhouette should tell you something he
wouldn't make one
them so obviously look like back ago if
there wasn't some kind of meaning behind
it but I know what you're thinking how
could this be back ago given that deck
who was in fact looking at the previous
users of one for all well my friends the
answer essentially boils down to this
man all for one's brother imagine this
like him you possessed a quirk that
allowed you to transfer quirks but you
could only ever use this power if
someone eats your DNA like a strand of
hair and you simultaneously have to will
them to have your quirk being completely
rational there is no scenario in which
you ever just happen to discover that
not even by accident in the world of my
hero academia there are no manuals there
is no book that tells you how to use
your own individual power and on that
basis the notion that all for one's
brother just happened to discover that
he could transfer quirks if he wanted it
to be passed on while someone was eating
his DNA is quite frankly impossible even
the master of quarks himself
all-4-one believed that his brother was
Quercus that's partly the reason why he
gave his brother the stockpiling power
in the first place
no one knew this guy had a transfer
quirk and the nature of the quirk meant
that no one would ever discover it at
random either but the main point is this
the only way the brother could have
found out is if someone told him it was
their nana shamora was told by her
predecessor she then told all my and all
my told deku and can we all remember how
shocked Becky's face was when he heard
that he had to eat a piece of almost DNA
it's just not something that people
would naturally think to do so with all
that on the table how did the first user
of one for all find out that he could
transfer quirks there is not a single
person alive in his time not even his
older brother who was aware of this
power and could have told him the answer
has been staring us in the face back ago
one of only a handful of people to ever
know of one for all was sent back in
time by an older version of arey who had
mastered her rewind quirk to show the
first user the he could transfer quirks
thus becoming the second user himself
and completing the fixed time loop and
he doesn't change the past by doing this
either because he always was the second
user and before we properly dive into
this let me just briefly explain the
theoretical concept of a fixed time loop
this is a concept in physics
is quite similar to a self-fulfilling
prophecy in a time loop like this a
sequence of events is triggered by one
specific event but that specific event
that caused everything to happen was
actually the result of some one time
traveling back and causing that event
but this is where it gets really trippy
because the person who went back in time
too cause that event and you know set
everything in motion only did so because
that event had already occurred in their
time that's what we're dealing with here
back ago lived in a world where one
floor had always existed but was then
sent back in time to tell the first user
how to use it but he was only able to do
this because one floor all had always
existed and therefore he had the
knowledge necessary to go back and tell
the first user but anyway with the time
travel explanation out of the way
I'm gonna explain to you how everything
ties in together we established earlier
that Shigure achey is getting a powerup
in the manga that will allow him to
somehow take one for all on the basis
that horikoshi is not a writer who just
put stuff like that in there for no
reason and just to troll you Shigure Aki
will at some point in the future take
one for all from Deku with the power of
one for all coupled with his already
powerful decay quark and the full army
of the paranormal Liberation Front he
will destroy hero Society and for the
record if you don't know what the
paranormal Liberation Front is then you
should probably watch my video breaking
down the my villain academia arc anyway
after sugar Aki takes one for all he
fulfills his dream of destroying society
after this they'll likely be a time skip
and this is something that horikoshi has
actually hinted at recently in an
interview he did for the new my hair
academia movie after a sufficient time
skip I believe that arey would be able
to focus her quark in a way that would
allow her to rewind people back in time
if only for a couple hours or a few days
and we spoke about this earlier but this
is a logical application of her rewind
quark rather than rewinding the
individual she can now rewind the time
directly around an individual thus
sending them into the past but moving on
given that Shigure aki has one for all
he's able to talk to the vestiges within
one fer all one of them being his
grandmother Nana shamora while all hope
might seem lost for the heroes
back ago deku and nana shamora have a
grand plan that transcends time itself
remember because back ago is the second
user of one for all nana shamora as the
seventh user has already seen his
memories from before he traveled back in
time therefore she knows the sequence of
events that occurred in order for him to
go back in time and because she has this
knowledge she sets the events into
motion by telling Shigure aki that baku
go is the true creator of one for all
and that as long as Baku is alive the
heroes have hoped this would cost your
garage to go on a hunt for back ago who
is now older due to the time skip now
with shigaraki looking for back ago the
heroes will naturally catch word of this
and through the grapevine they'll find
out that Shigure aki believes that baku
go is the true creator of one for all
this sequence of events will send the
heroes on a massive arc to find the last
remnants of the quark enhancing drug
trigger now trigger was a big part of
the Maya hero academia vigilante
spin-off but it's also become a big part
of the manga as well in the overall arc
we see numerous characters using trigger
with the most notable probably being
mimic to put it bluntly trigger makes
any character overpowered now when the
heroes eventually find this they'll give
the drug to Arry which will supercharge
her quirk beyond comprehension and allow
her to send back a go back in time over
a hundred years so that he can complete
the causal time loop by telling the
first user of one-for-all how to
transfer the quark back ago essentially
sacrifices himself as he's taking a
one-way ticket back in time with no hope
of return this would be an amazing
moment for his character and would show
insane development back ago has never
been the type of character to make the
sacrifice but this sacrifice by going
back in time it would ensure a few
things that I haven't even mentioned yet
so firstly he'll meet the first user of
one for all and tell him that he has the
ability to transfer his quirks then he
will receive the power from that user
and become the second holder of one for
all
Bukka go will then help cultivate the
power through the years but what I
hadn't mentioned is this in the manga
it's revealed that Deku is the first and
only user of one for all who is able to
access the quirks of the previous users
so buyback ago going back in time he's
essentially allowing deku in the future
to access his explosion quark horikoshi
has made it abundantly clear that Declan
has been studying back ago ever since
they were kids
and for those of you that have seen the
anime you'll know that Dec who's
actually copied a few of his moves
already if anyone could use the
explosion of quark as good as back ago
its Deku and the reason Deku is able to
have one for all after sugar aki taking
it is because he has rewound his body
back into a time when he had it and this
is by no means a stretch as we saw
during the overhaul arc that every
rewound deck whose body to allow him to
use a hundred percent of one for all and
that was when she had zero training with
her quark additionally by back ago going
back in time his spirit will be able to
appear as a vestige inside one for all
in the future and sort of like having
Thor's hammer I believe that his Shigure
aki possessed the one for walk work
he wouldn't actually be able to use it
to its full potential the reason I say
that is that one for all was created and
cultivated to defeat all for one
so because Shigure aki is almost
apprentice there's no way he's gonna
have access to all the cool features of
the quark for example accessing previous
quirks or seeing all the memories of its
previous users now about this grand plan
with nana shamora and Deku win back ago
the sequence of events that we've seen
so far would lead to the final battle of
my hero academia because back ago was
the second user he is now a vestige
within the quark and backer goes plan is
to lead both Deku and Shigure Aki to a
specific location where they can Duke it
out remember at this point Shigure aki
has destroyed super human society and he
has an entire army to command he's
essentially a king and a king never goes
anywhere alone but the vestige of Bach
ago will somehow trick Shigure aki into
going to a location where Deku will also
be and crucially Shigure aki will have
to be alone this would at least give
Deku a fighting chance of defeating
shigaraki and returning society back to
the way it used to be
unlike tomara deck who has access to all
the quartz within one for all could you
imagine this fight one one for all user
with access to all the quirks against
Shigure aki who has access to both one
for all and the decay quark
just be the best farmable only you could
possibly imagine and regardless of how
the fight between deco and shaker rocky
turns out the fact remains is that it
was all set into motion by Bach ago and
Nana shamora with Baku go being the
secret hero and because back ego went
back in time he had the benefit of not
only giving Deku explosion but ensuring
the timeline remained intact and that
one for all was created and with that
we've come to the end of this theory as
you can see it draws a lot of these
story points that horikoshi is
introduced for example the drug trigger
and the spirits of one for all and
obviously back ago looking like a
previous user of one for all but with
that said let's get into some Twitter
questions so the first question we have
is from Tana who says that it would
leave a huge time paradox since if the
first user of one-for-all never knew how
the quirk worked it would never get to
the point where BAC ago himself could
learn how the quirk works and I totally
see where you're coming from but the
nature of the question is kind of flawed
and the reason I say that is because
you're thinking about time in a linear
fashion as human beings we constantly
think of time as one straight line that
keeps moving forward but the concept of
a causal time loop is different from
this perception in this causal loop the
time line has always been based around
baku go going back and telling the first
user there never was a timeline in which
BAC ago wasn't the second user so the
premise of this question is flawed
moving on the next question arcs why
Nana Shamwari would help sugar Aki and I
think what they mean is why would Nana
shamora tell sugar Aki that BAC ago was
a threat and the answer to this is that
Nana shamora has seen back and gos
memories she's seen what motivated him
to make different decisions in his life
and one of the things that motivated him
to travel back in time was that the
heroes heard through the grapevine that
sugar Aki was looking for BAC ago
because he believes that BAC ago was
somehow the creator of one for all and
this is when things begin to click for
the heroes as deku having previously
seen the vestige that looks like BAC ago
goes on one of his famous rants and
convinces everyone that this is the best
course of action to take now this next
question is quite interesting what if
BAC ago intentionally modelled himself
his look in his hairstyle and everything
else after the second user of one for
all
and I have a pretty simple answer to
that question if baku go had modeled his
costume after a previous hero from God
knows how long ago in the exact same way
but we know that Kirishima models
himself after the hero known as crimson
Raya and we know that deku models
himself after all my you think that
Batgirl would at least once referenced
the famous hero who inspired his costume
and look it's a bit weird for back you
go to model himself after someone that
no one knows or no one has ever
mentioned and by that same token that's
the same reason why I doubt it's a
family member as well Barca goes
personality is such that he wouldn't be
able to keep something like that to
himself
like come on guys this is my Coco's
personality if he was proud enough of a
previous family member or a previous
hero to model his look after them you
can bet your ass he's gonna talk about
it but yeah we all know that he idolizes
all my he's never mentioned another hero
or a family member or anything like that
that has inspired him more than all
might now these next comments were more
of a statement than a question but I
figured I should address them so the
first one says that there's nothing up
until now that implies that era can send
people back in time to which I say of
course there is the fact we've seen her
apply time travel on people's individual
bodies is pretty indicative of the fact
that with actual experience
rewinding the space surrounding a person
is not that far like it's not a big
stretch the fundamental nature of Ares
quark is to rewind that's why it's
called rewind just because she has only
rewound people's bodies so far it's
simply showing us what an untrained
application of her power can do now this
one is quite similar and it states that
Ares quark is just said to work on
living beings again let's just take a
step back here characters within the
world of my hero academia they base
their decisions purely based on what
they see the only reason anyone would
ever say every squark is limited to
living beings is because that's all
they've ever seen so far and the reason
they've only seen that is because she's
a six-year-old child who has never
trained her quark let's imagine it's a
week from now and aeri manages to rewind
an apple suddenly those same characters
who said that she could only manipulate
living things would go away no she could
manipulate inanimate objects as well
it's purely based on what they've seen
so far and the fundamental nature of
finding things means that how quick
could be used in the future in this way
and because Aires quark is still in its
infancy placing limitations on it
doesn't really make much sense at all so
I can't wait to see where it goes from
here but regardless of that whatever you
thought about this theory or this video
please be sure to do two things first
let me know in the comments if you think
that Bach ago is the vestige that Dec
you saw in his vision I think the fact
that horikoshi has intentionally hidden
this character and the design is so
similar to back a ghost silhouette I
know Hiroko she has done this for a
reason and whilst my theory might not be
the exact theory there is definitely
something to do with back go in here for
sure either that or horikoshi is just a
massive troll and secondly don't forget
to subscribe as I know this video is
gonna take a long time to edit so I
would really appreciate your support as
it's a lot of work to make these videos
and put them out thanks for watching
guys peace out